lots of pressure on this film to do more
yeah it's not like the first time around
you tried to do less what we thought is
going in on half pump it up well I you
know I think that in you know guardians
of galaxy vol 2 I just wanted to
continue the story in the truthful way
from the first movie and I think that
meant going deeper into the characters
and getting to know those characters
more I think the first movie was the
story of Peter Quill's star-lord the
second movie is centered around
star-lord in some ways but in some ways
not each of them has their own equally
independent and important story look out
I tried dice and Dave Bautista was
saying that he loves doing green screen
scenes with you because you give so much
what do you do for your actors to ground
them in these freezy realities that
often are not there I would like to know
what what Batista's does about but it's
like I think I just you know I I have a
very big imagination and at the
beginning of the script stage I created
all in my head and then it's simply a
matter of trying to make the movie look
like what's in my head for the rest of
it and so it's just a lot of legwork
because the fun part is really at the
writing stage so by the time I get to
the green screen with Dave Bautista I'm
able to describe pretty specifically
what's going on around him
yeah I guess yeah I feel a general
unselfish love first murder yeah sure no
no I don't know you know the first time
I made Chris Pratt very funny and he's
not able to do that so the second time I
wrote a very dry boring guy which is
more like Chris Pratt so it made it a
lot easier no you know listen I think
you know Chris has a very specific way
of talking this he's from Washington me
but he almost has a southern charm about
him
so I made that a part of the character
you know Bautista has a very dry very
quiet voice that I put the good use for
is in the first movie I had him yelling
a lot he doesn't really like yelling
he's not you know that's not his thing
it's more his dry sense of wit and for
Zoey I think that there was this she's
got such this strong personality and
underneath it is this very sort of
vulnerable candor
this almost motherliness maybe even
perhaps because she has two little kids
that makes her a very strong personality
and so to bring out both of those parts
of herself was was part of the challenge